buh-bah yes my son tell me a story which
one the story of whom the exchange with
which this movie Black Panther begins
encompasses most of what the movie is
about connection to the father as the
past tradition identity strength as well
as the guarding of a home a secret
precious place the home as mother sister
wife that feed us give us the resources
and matter to maintain our identity
Black Panther shows us the possibility
and dangers of identity
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
as usual there is quite a lot to deal
with in black panther but hopefully I
can pull out a thread which will help
one see the basic pattern the movie sets
up a secret city which is hidden for
most people it's more technologically
advanced than any other place on earth
though still it maintains a deep
connection to ancient traditions the
secret city as the projection of an
ideal has both the futuristic tech of a
science fiction movie yet the people are
still herdsmen they live in huts and
fulfill our longing for being connected
to nature
the contrasts lay themselves out
spaceships in majestic waterfalls
skyscrapers overlooking markets where
people buy baskets and the technology
they have is also portrayed as a form of
magic a food which can bring about
mystical experiences and superpowers
I think it's precisely the joining of
all these extremes and seeming
contradictions a union of hope for the
future and nostalgia for the past a
union of technical skill with spiritual
connection all of this is what makes
Wakanda a place of dreams where the
impossible is possible and I think it's
all of this which also made the idea of
Wakanda so attractive to the viewing
public so we start the movie in 1992 and
the brother of the king of Wakanda has
been living in a foreign land in the
United States and seeing the suffering
of the African Americans he has become
radicalized and plans violent actions
against the system the leaders have been
assassinated communities flooded with
drugs and weapons they are overly
policed and incarcerated all over the
planet our people suffer because they
don't have the tools to fight back now I
promised myself I wouldn't be too
political in my commentary but I think
it's important to mention one political
aspect if we want to understand what the
movie is about
in this first encounter the movie black
panther shows us that it is not about
africa in any significant manner it's
rather about the perception and the
experiences of african-americans and
this is totally fair but I think it's
important to perceive this clearly as it
will be a key to understanding the
unfolding plot the idea that the brother
of the king of Wakanda would go to the
United States to have an awakening to
the suffering of African people is I
mean at first glance rather strange I
mean seeing that what Conda is somewhere
in the Great Lakes region of Africa I
mean there would have been many things
close to his doorstep to see I mean in
1992 is one year after the dictator
Mobutu Sese Seko pushed his own military
to terrorize and pillage the city of
Kinshasa one year later a second
pillaging would leave the city in a
post-apocalyptic state from which it has
never recovered a little later in 1994
would occur the Rwandan genocide where
800,000 people were hacked to death in
the streets the genocide would lead to a
series of reprisals meddlings from
neighboring countries culminating in the
breakdown of eastern congo to a state of
anarchy of tribal fighting starvation
and rape in which it is estimated that
over 5 million people have died so at
first glance when the black panther
whose country is right there
where all of this is still happening now
in 2018 would glibly announced that he's
opening up what Conda and starting an
outreach in the United States I mean
this just clinches how the myth of
Wakanda and it's narrative is addressing
the questions and experiences of African
Americans and it portrays Africa as an
origin myth a kind of Eden from which
the African American identity has been
alienated understanding how Wakanda is a
mythic version of Africa is important
because it will also help to understand
the character of kill
and especially understand how what Conda
is presented in in the movie as a kind
of condensation a culture which visually
unites extremely diverse and conflicting
imagery with super modern futuristic
things everything is joined together so
the structure of what Conda is mythical
and that that's how it's presented and
there you see that political accession
is condensed right into direct ritual
combat reducing political conflict to
its most imagistic form you know what in
our world happens indirectly through
debate posturing and insults a notable
structure in the movie is also that the
king is surrounded by women his family
of course but his personal guard are
also women and this might seem
surprising to some but in a way I found
such an arrangement to be a powerful
solution to the modern desire of showing
strong warrior you know female character
types kings and emperors have often
surrounded themselves with eunuchs or
else foreigners because these these
Outsiders would be loyal to the throne
rather than looking to possibly use herb
the king and so to a guard of women
protecting the king would be loyal in
the same manner since they cannot access
the throne directly and this
relationship to the male king with a
buffer of the feminine surrounding him
is also a microcosm of how all identity
works so think of the traditional image
of Christ appearing in the center of his
mother and remember also even that the
Virgin Mother the Virgin Mother of God
herself is represented as a guard as the
guardian of Constantinople because she's
made akin to a wall or a closed gate so
the notion of a female regimen of guards
has existed in several guises in ancient
Africa and even recently general Qadhafi
had his own you know
Amazonian guard so because what Conda is
completely closed off it is both strong
and vulnerable like with
anything precious what Condon's feel
that they need to protect and keep their
treasure their vibranium you know their
technology of course but ultimately it's
about identity the question of identity
follows through the entire movie who are
we what is the extent of our different
identities
I mean who should we share with kill
monger and his father somehow identify
with all other people who share their
skin color and they think that what
Conda should extend its identity and
power to all those people but T'Challa
doesn't see it that way his identity is
limited to his royal tribe and then to
Wakanda as the union of five tribes but
his fear of action it limits itself to
that border and the problem of identity
is not an easy question to answer I mean
how do we know what the shape and limits
of our identities are how do we define
us you know when does this us get
activated I mean most people would pitch
in and help a nearby family you know if
their house burned down but there are
houses burning down all the time all
over the world and I mean why don't we
pitch in when a house burns down in
Kyrgyzstan the question of identity
plays itself out as a series of embedded
microcosms so within what Conda there is
one tribe which is excluded from the
city yet it's still considered in a way
the margin of Wakanda in the same manner
kill monger has been excluded from the
city as well
he is half wakandan yet he demands to be
let in and finally the question arises
of whether people of all African descent
sufficiently share the wakandan identity
in order to be somehow included in that
identity or in relationship with that
identity it is not our way to be judge
jury and executioner for people who are
not our own not wrong but didn't life
started right here on this continent
so in all people your people I am NOT
King
of all people I am king of Wakanda these
questions of identity are all images of
each other so what is ambiguous comes to
pose a challenge and a threat to the
authority the challenge spouted is is
mostly a question the question is what
about me I mean do I have access to the
center how do I participate in this
common identity and so this question
repeats itself over and over in the
challenge of mbaku who is in the margin
of Wakanda and the question of T'Challa
is ex girlfriend Nakia who's a spy in a
foreign land and this culminates in the
challenge posed by kil monger who is the
most ambiguous of all a half what conned
in orphan without a father who is
presented as this abandoned lost sheep
which were Conda has failed to bring in
what happened to kill monger his
alienation from Wakanda is also
presented through a series of complex
analogies to the african-american
experience of fatherlessness
and also as being sold into slavery just
burn me in the ocean
well my assess is that jump from ships
because they know death was better than
bondage so the sudden appearance on the
edge of what Conda of kill monger as
this ambiguous figure as this thing
which does not fit into a clear inside
or outside puts in question the
stability and truth of the established
order quite appropriately this is shown
as revealing the secret sin of the
Father since the appearance of kill
monger exposes that the old king killed
his brother and abandoned the boy in
order to as they say themselves maintain
the lie in the Bible we speak of
uncovering nakedness there is the story
of Noah after the flood who gets drunk
in his tent and takes off his clothes
his son Ham sees the nakedness and
informs his brothers hams
punishment is to be exiled from the
family and now so here in the movie we
have the same structure but let's say
moving back in this ambiguous foreigner
comes to reveal the the nakedness of two
challahs father his insufficiency and
this doubt makes T'Challa question the
pristine authority which he had
proceeded in the past questions the
actions of his father questions also the
legitimacy of his own identity his world
is no longer stable and so in a manner
it is this doubt in to challenge which
makes him lose the battle with kill
monger makes him lose his kingship and
be plunged into chaos he falls into
death and finds himself in the
underworld represented by the cave
dwelling ape like marginal tribe of
mbaku
because kill monger is the victim of the
old king because he has been completely
segregated from Wakanda and also because
he is motivated by resentment how do you
think your ancestors got these you think
they paid a fair price what did they
take it like they took everything else
it would have been very difficult for
him to return to Wakanda and simply
enter as a normal wakandan it was almost
impossible for him to be accepted
normally the only way for him to become
what Condon is to take the throne and
reshape Wakanda into his own image
ultimately he hates what conduct what he
really wants is to burn it to the ground
and use whatever power he can get from
it to fuel his own resentment and
revolutionary agenda
as the chala enters the grave he's
tended by the women linked to his
identity his mother his sister and his
future wife Nakia and if in the first
ritual death he faced his father and was
connected to his father now he faces his
father's sin and that's where his father
called him to stay in death but to
challenge that he cannot let this stand
he must fix the situation he must
recover redress his father and so once
he awakens we have a more complete
resurrection of T'Challa we always have
to remember that the margin the animal
part of us the body and ultimately death
is also potentiality it is the potential
into which I can grow which can be
changed into glory and so as to Tala
goes into death if mbaku was the margin
the Challenger to his authority T'Challa
is able to gather that periphery to
himself and as he returns to reclaim his
throne he will have been able to turn
Baku's Tribe into a weapon to help him
stop a more dangerous foreigner who
wished to burn down the whole world this
image can help us to understand this
notion of turning death against death
this notion of the monster as a defender
against bigger and badder monsters so
have been able to ally himself with his
former challenger to chalice kingship is
not only restored but it has in fact
increased when he finally was able to
recover his throne
so out of the old king had come to black
panthers two sons you could say one
which is the clear continuation of
identity and stability and one which is
the accidental result of a lie and of
killing his brother you see as the uncle
of the boy the old king would have
replaced his father would have been his
guardian so even though T'Challa
understands that his father is also the
unwitting cause of kill mongers
situation he must still face his double
he must still face this dark reflection
in order to restore balance and this is
also why though to chalak kills kill
monger he also retains a sense of
kinship and compassion for his cousin
finally having seen his father's sin his
excessive desire to isolate Wakanda
T'Challa is also made more complete
understanding that what conduct cannot
be completely isolated from the rest of
the world but has to remain connected to
the outside in order to prevent other
similar events and this is what prompts
him to open up
what conduct to the rest of the world
now I have to admit that the last speech
made by the king to the UN is a bit
problematic because rather than finding
a kind of balance in a manner that would
have that we would have hoped he seems
now to go to the other extreme and he
speaks of any division as being an
illusion of all humanity being like one
tribe he says that the wise build
bridges not barriers which of course is
very is a very strange thing to say for
a king who will Stuart King first of all
who will still have to protect a
treasure which is the most valuable
resource in the entire world the truth
is that we always need both we need
bridges and barriers we need stable
identities as well as places of
hospitality and generosity for us to
fully thrive so I hope you enjoyed my
analysis of Black Panther there is a lot
of things happening first of all I
really want to thank the people that had
been supporting me on patreon you're
really pushing me further and further
it's very exciting I put I put a number
you know to to kind of signal to me that
I need to take this to the next level it
was $2,000 a month and and we're almost
there and so I decided I'm just gonna go
ahead and push through and so I I've
already put up the first episode of a
podcast version of these YouTube videos
and I will be trying to put them out
regularly put out all the videos those
that that can be put into podcast form
hopefully we'll catch up and at some
point I might even be producing podcasts
exclusively and then also videos on the
other side so that you know there'll be
all of that happening at the same time
and then in the near future I will be
putting out a website where all of this
information can come together and be
putting out transcripts and possibly
even maybe having some original blog
posts being posted there so you know and
I'm slowly going to phase down my icon
carving I still have quite a few orders
ahead of me but I will probably actually
stop taking orders until I I settle I
settle all of this and try to get it to
to make sense let's say I'm also excited
that in the last few days I noticed and
someone pointed me to a new Facebook
group which has been started to discuss
the symbolic world and the videos that
we're doing so you can check that out up
with the link in the description and
there's also a sub read reddit which was
started by someone and so you can check
that out as well I told the people on
reddit that if they can get organized
and if they get you know about 50 people
let's say that I would be willing to do
and ask me anything on Reddit and so go
ahead and find that and we'll see how
far that goes so I'm excited to see
what's happening there are more videos
being prepared as we speak and so I'll
see all of you soon